Hello, my name is Zisl Slepovitch
and I'm musician-in-residence at Yale
University's Fortunoff Video Archive
for Holocaust Testimonies.
This video series is designed as a companion
to our album, Where Is Our Homeland,
which is the first volume in the Archive's
ongoing effort to present songs
and poems performed by survivors in
testimonies given to the Fortunoff Archive
over the last 40 years.
You can learn more about the project on the
Archive's website, songsfromtestimonies.org.
Where Is Our Homeland?
Songs from Testimonies.
Vol. One was recorded in 2019
by the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble, featuring
renowned singer Sasha Lurje,
Craig Judelman on the violin, Joshua
Camp on the accordion, keyboards and
guitar, Dmitry Ishenko on the
bass, and myself on woodwinds.
The songs in this collection differ vastly
in terms of style, social and historical
background, language, and many other
aspects, but collectively they
create a multidimensional picture of
Jewish life before and during World
War II.
Several songs that we are presenting here
were actually the beginning of this music
project carried out by the archive,
and they all came from
Liubov' K.'s testimony.
Liubov' K.
was born and raised and lived her life
in Zvenigorodka, in Ukraine,
and she ended up with many
of her fellow citizens
in a slave labor camp
suffering hunger,
cold, torture,
loss of family, friends
and homes.
Two of her four songs that she
presented did not have
any music.
She recited them as poems.
So I took liberty to write music
to those poems
in the style that would be adequate and
representative of the music
popular at the time in Eastern Europe
and in the Soviet Union, in
Ukraine possibly.
And this song that tells
the story of Stepan,
the Ukrainian collaborationist guard,
an extremely cruel person.
I use the genres of tango,
which was a very
young genre at the time, and
military march.
I sometimes turn to military feel
there.
Stepan "the Blond," a guard so strict.
Day in, day out, with his rifle he sits.
Dutifully doing his duties,
Law and Order are his domain.
But this gang of ours is very naughty.
They don’t want to listen to their Blond.
He only has to turn his back,
Off to town (to beg for
food) they run like rabbits.
So once, on their day off, this brave Ten
Went running to the village.
When the Blond learned
of it at the inspection
He decided to teach them a little lesson.
When they returned, the Blond was waiting:
“Where have you been,
who gave you permission?”
“We beg: forgive us,
it won’t happen again.”
“I shall forgive,” he said,
but thought: “Just you wait.”
The next day he got his Ten together,
And brought them to
the German to be judged.
“We are lost, doomed, never to return!
For a piece of bread we’ll meet our end.”
But, alas, every one of them returned,
And a delightful treat awaited them.
The Blond prepared a tasty breakfast
For each of his Ten — 25 hard ones.
The ramrod whipped, and the moans wheezed.
And our gang went down in tears and terror.
To the side the Blond was
sitting, smiling, satisfied,
Having taught these naughty
Ten such a tidy lesson.
Stepan "the Blond," a guard so strict.
Day in, day out, with his rifle he sits.
Dutifully doing his duties,
Law and Order are his domain.
But this gang of ours is very naughty.
They don’t want to listen to their Blond.
He only has to turn his back,
Off to town (to beg for
food) they run like rabbits.
So once, on their day off, this brave Ten
Went running to the village.
When the Blond learned
of it at the inspection
He decided to teach them a little lesson.
When they returned, the Blond was waiting:
“Where have you been,
who gave you permission?”
“We beg: forgive us,
it won’t happen again.”
“I shall forgive,” he said,
but thought: “Just you wait.”
The next day he got his Ten together,
And brought them to
the German to be judged.
“We are lost, doomed, never to return!
For a piece of bread we’ll meet our end.”
But, alas, every one of them returned,
And a delightful treat awaited them.
The Blond prepared a tasty breakfast
For each of his Ten — 25 hard ones.
The ramrod whipped, and the moans wheezed.
And our gang went down in tears and terror.
To the side the Blond was
sitting, smiling, satisfied,
Having taught these naughty
Ten such a tidy lesson.
To the side the Blond was
sitting, smiling, satisfied,
Having taught these naughty
Ten such a tidy lesson.
A month after Liubov' K.
and her fellow prisoners were taken from
the Zvenigorodka ghetto to the Nemorozh
labor camp north of the city,
conditions in the camp became so crowded
that the German authorities decided to split
the camp in two.
Liubov', and half of the Nemorozh prisoners
were transferred to Smiltchytsi,
a village approximately 12
kilometers northwest of Nemorozh.
Later that year, on November 2,
1942, the German gendarmerie
liquidated the Nemorozh camp,
executing all of the prisoners who
remained there.
Liubov' K. and the other prisoners who had
been transferred to Smiltchytsi remained
there until December 1942,
when they were transferred yet again, this
time to Budyshche, a village
eight kilometers northeast of Smiltchysti.
Conditions in Budyshche were somewhat
better than Nemorozh and Smiltchytsi
for two main reasons.
First, the prisoners were housed
in a village clubhouse
rather than in barns.
As Liubov' recalls, "The
building wasn't heated, but the floor
was wooden instead of dirt, and
at least it was an enclosed space."
Second, the villagers of Budyshche
and the nearby village of Shesteryntsi
were remarkably generous towards the labor
camp prisoners.
Liubov' recalls, "They were
wonderful people.
All we can do is say thank you to them for
the rest of our lives.
Of course, we would like to express our
gratitude to them somehow.
They would come to the camp, they would
persuade the politsai, bring us
half liters, bring us pieces of bread,
a potato here and there.
And if they lived nearby, something hot
to eat.
They really supported us."
As time went on, the prisoners themselves
became more daring.
On their way back to the camp after a hard
day's labor on the Transit Highway IV
project, they would run in pairs
into the village to beg for something to
eat.
It was one such foray into a
neighboring village that inspired the
song "Stepan." As
Liubov' recalls, in general,
the Ukrainian auxiliary police who
guarded the camp would turn a blind
eye to the prisoner's brief absences.
As Liubov' puts it, "The
politsai had been with us so long, they
knew that we wouldn't run away."
While these temporary absences could be
overlooked, any actual escape
would entail severe consequences
for the remaining prisoners in the camp.
The German overseers had a rule
that if one prisoner ran
away from the camp,
10 innocent prisoners would be shot.
This threat proved to be a strong deterrent
against any plans of escape.
As Liubov' puts it, "We
didn't want to be the cause of others'
death.
We decided that whatever happened, it
would happen to all of us together."
So despite the guards generally permissive
attitude towards temporary absences,
on one unfortunate Sunday,
Liubov' and nine other prisoners snuck
out to the village during a roll call.
The blond guard Stepan met them at
the gate as they returned, demanding
to know where they had been.
The prisoners apologized profusely
and promised not to venture out again.
Much to their surprise, Stepan didn't
punish anyone immediately.
Instead, he waited until the following day,
Monday.
During that morning's roll call, he
demanded, "the ten of you, step forward."
While everyone else was taken out to work
in the forest that day, Stepan
took his ten unfortunate prisoners
to Lysyanka.
The group was fully
convinced that they were
being taken to the gendarmerie to be shot.
But instead, Stepan
took them to the highway
department in Lysyanka, where
the director and foreman of the highway
department worked.
There they were greeted by a young mean
German by the name of Hans.
Hans ordered Stepan to give
them each twenty lashes with a
ramrod.
And that is exactly what Stepan did.
The following day.
Tuesday, Liubov' and the other
nine prisoners ate their usual breakfast,
watery gruel, and then one
by one Stepan and one other
guard gave them each twenty five lashes
with a ramrod in the kitchen.
As Liubov' recalls, "We
crawled out of the kitchen on all fours,
and after that meeting we went back to
work."
To immortalize this agonizing experience,
the prisoners wrote a song describing the
brutality of handsome, yet heartless
Stepan.
Like the other three songs that Liubov'
shares in her testimony, this ode
to Stepan was composed collectively
by the prisoners.
As Liubov' explains,
"Everyone wrote the songs all together.
This one would give a word, that one would
give two.
This one, a line, and the next would add
another. That's how it came together for
us." While the lyrics of
this song described their ordeal in
unflinchingly factual terms,
in a certain sense, by writing this
song, the prisoners were able to have
the last laugh at Stepan's expense.
He tried to break their will, and yet they
still had the power to compose a song
about their blond tormentor.
Because songs like these were not committed
to paper, but instead were memorized,
if even one of the camp inmates
survived, their collective
history would survive as well, along
with the identity of their tormentors.
While Liubov' does not shy away from
describing the cruelty of Ukrainian
collaborators like Stepan,
her testimony also pays grateful
tribute to the local Ukrainian villagers
who brought food to Liubov' and her fellow
prisoners while they were in the Budyshche
labor camp.
Complex accounts of collaboration
and compassion are just one of the
aspects that make survivor testimonies
like Liubov's completely
invaluable in preserving the history
of the Holocaust.